hey guys this is andrew for
tradingsensors.com i'm a professional
trader and i've been working for several
big investment banks like hsbc or
commerce bank and
right now i'm doing some youtube videos
uh because i want to pass the knowledge
guys i'm a pro trader i've been using
technical analysis a lot
to help me to make any trading decision
and i can see that a lot of you
uh actually are looking for some
information about how portrayed as work
and what is actually working or not
working so i'm here to tell you what is
working for me
so today i want to talk about all these
penny stocks where i can see there is a
lot of
buying interest and i can see that you
know on wall street bets on
reddit on twitter everybody is talking
about this in my family people calling
me like hey bro what do you think about
the stock
and i checked so now i'm always on this
forums and i checked
list of all of the stocks and i'm here
to tell you what
which one for me are good or not and
what i would do
for what reasons so right now i want to
talk about
amc let's get into it
[Music]
so let's talk about amc so for those who
watch my previous videos i have a list
that i'm finding on twitter on reddit on
wall street bets i'm just you know
hanging out on this forums talking with
people and trying to find
you know all the information so you know
they give all of that a lot of them are
giving
you know their list of the potential
targets and
i'm here to you know check everything
and tell you what i
think is going to work or not to do that
i'm checking the market capitalization
and the short
interest the reason behind is that if
the market capitalization is small then
it's easier to
make the market move by putting all the
money together and this
is what this guy's actually doing and
you need to have a strong short interest
otherwise a short squeeze cannot happen
all right so the short interest is
created by hedge funds
and the show squeeze is created by the
redditors the guys that are actually
buying uh
all together so i've just done clds
which was a very nice target for me guys
because 35
of short interest one billion market cap
now i'm doing amc i've already done this
one but i want to give you an update
guys
so the short interest is much smaller
you know only 10
now you see it was higher before and the
reason behind guys
is that here a lot of hedge fund already
cut the position
so i'm not sure there's gonna be enough
power
for this stock to rebound just looking
at the short interest
now technically so i always do the same
thing guys uh you know i'm
on the log scale and i try to identify
actually i take the the last highs
you know that i connect together and i
can
check what is happening all right so
here
you can see that on the shorter term we
broke this
six level all right with the gap up then
we went higher
we broke this resistance as well that
was here connected with the two highs
that were there
and we didn't manage to stay above and
then we came back and now we're here so
what i see here guys is actually
something that
might go higher but definitely something
was missed in this rally all right the
hedge fund cut the position
and the price still went lower so i'm
not
very convinced that this would actually
go higher it's not my
first target you see we are trading
below eight so eight was the
three maximum that we had here let me
put this in red because it is now
resistance this is support
all right so we're having some support
at six we have some resistance at eight
and we have some more
resistance at ten so
what i would do in this situation i
would be about around six
and i would try to take my profits quite
early guys all right
let's be honest if i see this the price
around 10
i buy around six i sell around 10 and
then if you trade above 10 and that we
confirm
the breakout then i would be a buyer
above 10 as well
but i would buy the retest i wouldn't
buy the breakout
so that's it for me guys i hope you
enjoyed uh this analysis if you did
please don't forget to click the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new
and stay close to shore i see you guys